bombshell news for gta 6 your
playstation plus games for august and
some disappointing news for the knights
of the old republic remake all this on
today's gamespot news
a report from bloomberg's jason schrei
gives us the biggest info dump for grand
theft auto 6 that we've ever gotten both
for details on what to expect in the
game as well as behind the scenes at
rockstar on its development firstly
let's talk about the contents of the
game itself bloomberg reports that the
game will feature a latina character
making this the first playable woman in
a gta campaign this character will be a
part of a pair of leads that are meant
to be influenced by bonnie and clyde the
real life couple that went on a bank
robbing spree with their gang during the
great depression no word on whether
players will get to play as the other
character in the pairing the game has an
internal code name project americas as
it was initially meant to feature large
swaths of the american continent however
the scale of the game has been reduced
over time and will be set in the
universe's fictional depiction of miami
vice city the report includes the
details that the game will still be
quite large with more interior locations
than previous gta games and that the
developer will be adding additional
cities and content over time but when
can you play it some developers on the
team told bloomberg that it will be
released sometime in publisher take
two's fiscal 2024 which runs from april
2023 to march 2024 although some
interviewed believe that the game would
not hit that window and would release no
sooner than 2024 the game has been in
development since 2014 which if it were
to come out in 2024 would mean that
development will take 10 years a time
period in which rockstar has gone
through some dramatic changes in 2018
hundreds of rockstar employees spoke out
about issues with crunch and toxicity at
the developer which has reportedly led
to some massive cultural shifts at the
company employees informed trier that
morale at rockstar is at an all-time
high thanks to changes in scheduling
converting contractors to full-time
employees and the severance of several
managers that workers underneath them
deemed to be abusive and difficult to
work with this change changing culture
has guided the content of the game
itself aiming to not quote punch down on
marginalized groups and while previous
entries have largely been a satirical
look at the united states several
employees pointed out in the report that
satirizing today's united states is more
difficult thanks to the us already being
a parody of itself so if you're
disappointed that you have to wait for
gta 6 don't worry we're already living
it
something you won't have to wait as long
for is playstation plus august games
starting tuesday august 2nd if you have
any of the ps plus tiers you'll be able
to pick up tony hawk's pro skater
oneplus 2 yakuza like a dragon and
little nightmares at no additional cost
a recent reveal from gaming magazine for
mitsu showed that the next yakuza entry
yakuza 8 will feature the characters of
leica dragon so this is the perfect
pickup for anyone looking to jump into
that world and pro skater oneplus 2
might be the only way to get your tony
hawk fixed for a while as the legendary
skater revealed on stream that a remake
of three plus four was in development up
until activision folded developer
vicarious visions into working on call
of duty and plans for the remake were
scrapped speaking of scrapped remakes it
seems the knights of the old republic
remake from aspire is in dire straits
according to bloomberg the game's art
director jason miner and design director
brad prince have been abruptly fired in
follow-up meetings with the team at
large the higher ups told employees that
the project has been put on hold in the
meantime the studio will seek out and
pursue new contracts in may 2022 studio
saber interactive joined aspire in
developing the kotor remake according to
bloomberg's report employees at aspire
media now believe that saber interactive
may take over the project completely as
aspire moves on to other opportunities
and that is it for today's gamespot news
thank you so much for joining me let me
know in the comments below what you want
to see and be able to do in grand theft
auto 6 and we'll see you tomorrow right
here at gamespot